chaque 27 d'activité dernière
appartement de guy bedos est de ce fait
devrait y voit la ligne et un rôle
extrêmement précis qu depuis qu'il est
ici elle n'arrête pas d'ouvrir des
télégrammes il y en a certains que je ne
peux pas vous j y ai beaucoup et ça
c'est pas possible ça c'est mon milieu
ça c'est quelque chose qui est sa
maladie oui j'ai d'ailleurs je sais
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui nous console de
passer en première l'an des musiques
soul je sais que ça nous fait peur aussi
de les trouver en transe un instant moi
je le suis madame à l'intérieur se voit
pas riche
je triche d'ailleurs vous vous êtes bien
posée non pas vous avez déjà fait une
émission en direct vous vous étiez sur
l'antenne radio il ya quelques instants
vous avez bavarder avec gaza vague sur
jeu les joies de la culture
le plus dur est fait en ce moment là
c'est une forme l'idée de kerampuilh
sophie sophie daumier tout à l'heure
clanet dans le couloir d'à côté
aujourd'hui dit il n'a pas du tout oui
mais je dois dire je lai gelé
rassurez vous je laisse si vous saviez
mais je l'aide une bonne façon je veux
dire j'ai envie de m'amuser j'ai envie
d'amuser
ça c'est bien comme vous êtes plusieurs
de cet avis tous ceux qui sont dans la
salle et vous de votre côté et pour nous
amuser vous apporter ce sont je prends
pas mal de nouveautés oui vous avez
postale que depuis ce matin ça passe sur
les ondes alors je ne sais plus si c'est
tellement de travail si vite avec les
nouveaux moyens d'expression mais enfin
disons que ce sont les sketches de
l'année de la saison c'est se savait sur
quoi ils réapparaissent est alors en
scène comment sur quoi je suis là sur
une ovation
je vous trouvez en seul enregistré le
premier sketch ce sera c'est ça la
culture
écoutez comme ils ne seront pas tout à
l'heure dans la salle dite lors la
première phrase un petit cadeau
métamorphosé je suis métamorphosé ya
quatre mois je ne savais rien j'étais un
culte ignares à présent génie culture
énorme grâce à la télé et grâce à mon
père
mesdames en quatre mois je ne savais
rien céder à cuba il ya à présent j'ai
suturé la hat a été atteint mon père y
est moins mon père m'avait dit lucien
lui a fait rater les camionneurs 7 et 17
millions et la littérature
pourquoi l'importance des colts a que je
me souviens que tu es noyellois très peu
tendu on peut pas répondre de qualité
oui je me dis l'histoire 10 par an entre
450 et qu'un wagon de tête